welcome to our press conference uh
following our formal summit
we will be releasing the conclusions
all of them um in a short while
president you have the floor
[Music]
[Music]
sir
madam president you have the flow thank
you byron um dear xiao let me take the
opportunity to congratulate you first of
all
for the extension of your mandate as
president of the council so i'm very
much looking forward to the second round
indeed yesterday president zielenski
impressively described
the unfolding of putin's war
the atrocities and the cruelties the
ruthlessness of putin's army sparing
neither children nor women neither young
nor old
and president zielinski described the
courage of ukrainians
who are resisting bravely
they have the whole european union
behind them democracies of the world
stand together against putin's war
and if there's anything putin did not
expect it is our unity
it is a speed of our action and it is
our determination
we will further increase our support to
ukraine we will sharpen our sanctions
and we will break free from russian
fossil fuels
first on sanctions
the
four waves of sanctions we took against
russia are biting hard
they're running deep into the russian
economy
drying out the resources to finance this
war
now all our efforts should be on
enforcing these sanctions and on
preventing circumvention
and evasion
second on support to ukraine
right now around about 10 million
ukrainians are either internally
displaced or seeking shelter abroad
they need urgently our help
in ukraine we provide humanitarian aid
we are also actively working on securing
safe passage for humanitarian convoys
and i want to thank from the bottom of
my heart those eu countries bordering
ukraine which are welcoming refugees
with open arms
to support them we have made available
important sums of money
i'm talking about the 17 billion euros
mostly from flexibilized cohesion funds
this money can be used for schooling for
housing healthcare for
example the amounts are important
but we also need to know that speed
really matters at the moment being
and the money is needed now
and this is the reason why we're making
sure that 3.4 billion euros
of this bigger package of 17 billion
will be front loaded so to give
immediately liquidity to the member
states that are hosting refugees
we also support those in ukraine who so
bravely resist the kremlin's forces
ramped up our support to ukraine with 1
billion from the eu budget for military
assistance
and many eu members are delivering such
assistance on a bilateral basis
on top of this we have presented
measures to support food security and
agriculture in ukraine
because putin's war is starting to have
a serious impact on food security in
ukraine and globally
ukraine and russia together account for
one-third
of the world's wheat exports
therefore we must avoid a global food
crisis and we have to act now
we are providing
24.5 billion euros until 2024
to help the regions most affected by
food insecurity
third and finally on breaking free from
russia's fossil fuels
this morning president biden and i
agreed on an unprecedented partnership
to reduce europe's dependency on russian
gas
and in parallel
we agreed on this partnership to really
accelerate the green transition
as a first step the united states will
provide us with an additional
at least 15 billion cubic meter of lng
this year
in other words this replaces the amount
of russian lng for this year
and in the coming years
we're aiming for at least 50 billion
cubic meters per year
and this would be able to replace one
third of all russian gas supply to
europe
this is significant
and on top our investment will also pave
the way for the deployment of green
energy because the infrastructure
that we use for gas today and that we
are investing in
can also be used for clean hydrogen in
the future
this agreement with the united states
was a positive development ahead of the
leaders discussion on energy this
morning and this is my last remark
we looked at various options to question
the impact of high energy prices on
consumers and businesses
measures such as income support or state
aid vouchers reduce taxation price caps
modulating prices contracts for
difference etc
all options we presented have pros and
cons
but first and foremost we need to look
at the root causes of high electricity
prices and this is in big part high and
volatile gas prices
the energy mix and concrete situation in
our member states is very different
but we need to work together to pull our
weight
and this is why i advocated for strong
european approach
if we look at the gas market the
pipeline gas market
75
of the global pipeline gas market
is the european market so we have an
enormous purchasing power
therefore i welcome that we will now use
our collective bargaining power
instead of outbidding each other and
driving prices up we will pool our
demand
in addition
we must complete pipeline infrastructure
and ramp up our storage and the
interconnectors
we propose the minimum storage of 80
percent underground for next winter
rising to 90 percent then in the
following years this will be our
insurance policy against supply
disruption
but it is also time to look at the
design of our energy market you know
this topic this is the question of
decoupling the gas
price from the overall electricity price
we will present options for that in may
thank you very much
thank you madam president we'll just
take a couple of questions because it's
been a long day sylvia
martinez please come to the stand if you
can
hi
and i wanted to ask you one of the
biggest uh demands from spain it's been
the decoupling
and they're they're they have asked for
a special treatment because of the
situation of the
ivarian peninsula regarding their
interconnection are they going to get
this this i don't know exception they
are asking for
and uh
how do you see the possibility of for
them just fortunate in spain to fix
their own
price cut thank you
so yes we discussed that intensively and
indeed the iberian peninsula has a very
special situation
there the energy mix is with a high load
of renewables this is very good
and with very few interconnections only
and therefore we agreed on a special
treatment that is possible for the
iberian peninsula
so that uh the iberian peninsula can
deal with this very specific situation
they are in
and manage the the electricity prices in
the way uh that we have been discussing
at the council
andy
from the financial times please
good evening
you both mentioned the need to close
sanctions loopholes and make sure
they're effective now the us is talking
today about taking secondary sanctions
so in other words sanctioning entities
and uh companies in third countries that
are
circumventing uh eu and u.s sanctions is
that a route that the eu is looking to
go down
we had yesterday a very good debate we
spent in biden but also in the
framework of the the g7 on the sanctions
first element we have taken
unprecedented sanctions the fourth
package of sanctions and we are working
you know to implement those tensions
point one point two we are aware that
there are some loopholes that are
possible and that's why we we start the
commission you know to make sure that we
are able to to close as much as possible
those loopholes and point three we
understand also it's important to engage
with certain countries in order to
advocate to sensibilities to sensibilize
certain countries for them to to follow
the same approach on
ascensions and we are convinced that the
the center we have decided are painful
this was our common goal we want to be
painful
for the kremlin and we are also ready to
maintain our efforts and to and to see
if it is needed to deal with our
partners to take additional measures
as you know we have been very closely
coordinating with our friends allies and
partners
to shape and tailor these sanctions
because our economic systems are not
identical but different and we wanted to
have the same effect
this wasn't is successful
so we have a an enormous impact by these
sanctions
sanctions that are applied by
way over 40 countries by now that
represent more than half of the global
gdp
so this is really substantial
and therefore as we have different
systems but the same goal with the
sanctions uh we agreed now to really
look do deep into the loopholes we
discover now or the circumventions that
some try to take and to do everything
within the own respective system to
close the loopholes and to make the
circumventions impossible
thank you madam president and mr
president keep an eye out we're going to
publish the conclusions very shortly
thank you for attending bye
you